welcome back to las vegas now juna and
joey are a brother sister singer
songwriter country pop duo basically
they do it all and they are joining us
live via zoom to talk about all of the
exciting things they have going on how
are you guys
great how are you
great i i have a lot of questions for
you but i have to start with this
because i was reading a little bit about
you guys and what inspired you to start
singing and you referenced one of my
favorite movies tell me about the little
rascals and how that got you guys
starting to sing
so actually i used i still but i was
obsessed with that movie growing up and
i saw the scene where darla and alfalfa
were in the talent show
and i used to watch that movie like
every single day so it inspired me to
kind of just start music and and i
create like i want to be just like that
little girl you know singing on stage
with my brother and that's kind of what
inspired me to start music and that's
what made me play my first song yeah
that was like the first like movie we
would put into our mom's uh dvd and uh
just to watch it when we go to school or
anywhere um but yeah i started playing
sports and i eventually found out i
could sing i went to one of her lessons
and just music came about and ever since
then you know it's been we've been a duo
well i love that darla and alfalfa live
on so that is amazing and you guys have
gone viral on youtube tip talk you're
all over social media tell us just a
little bit about the inspiration for
your songs and your videos and what
you're working on now
so we actually just put out a song it's
called more than a maybe and we've been
loving it so far we wrote it up in
nashville and it's been great we
actually also put out a song called to
your heart braves which is about not
appreciating a great love that you have
with someone it's your heartbreaks not
knowing how much it'll affect you until
you don't have that person in your life
anymore so you have those two songs that
recently came out and people have been
loving them on tiktok and social media
so they've been doing really great yeah
we're actually working on new pete right
now uh working on some songs finding a
producer and i'm gonna record some new
music so hopefully you guys like it
and what's it like working together as
brother and sister i have a sister we
get along really well but everyone
always asks do we fight so what's your
guys dynamic do you guys usually see eye
to eye on everything
yeah
something that you know we're not really
agreeing with it's usually in writing
you know because we just both bring
different things to the table and we
have different ideas on things but
usually we're pretty good yeah we have
our moments but we're really good
yeah you guys basically finish each
other's sentences i'm loving this family
relationship you guys have going on here
and i'm really excited because i hear
you're going to give us a little taste
of one of your songs so i'm going to let
you guys take it away tell us the song
and i'm excited to hear it
okay so this song is called more than a
maybe and
you say it's about hoping for more than
maybe from that special something
all right i'm excited let's hear it
you're standing with your friends i'm
trying not to stare
looking my way while you're playing with
your hair
working up the nerve to cross that line
ask if you'd be in the party tonight
[Music]
please don't keep me in the time would
you be my blue
[Music]
a
baby
amazing i feel like i'm getting my own
private concert right now you guys are
awesome
you'll have to come visit us out here in
las vegas we're we're going to add it to
your tour stops and putting it out there
we'd love to
thank you guys so much congrats on
everything and best of luck i can't wait
to continue following along jc i'll send
it over to you all right